we sometimes joke around about this
phrase the Battle of ideas and I don't
know where it actually became
popularized I know that Dave Rubin on
the Rubin report uses it and it's become
sort of satirized in some ways and I
know that there are also other online
movements that focus on free speech that
talk about the battle of ideas but I
don't want to use it satirically here
because I actually want to talk about
something really serious that's going on
what I'm referring to when I talk about
the movement around the battle of ideas
and principles is sort of this
philosophy this overarching kind of
de-facto philosophy that has developed
where it's really popular to say what
matters most and arguably sometimes they
say what matters exclusively are the
underlying principles that we stand for
and that policy is sort of secondary
from that it flows naturally from our
principles and our ideas but you have to
first before you can really talk about
policy have your principles and ideas
straight and that's the tough work and
the rest is sort of easy and it often is
applied by the extreme forms of
libertarianism it also applies sometimes
like one example would be there's this
guy online called Carl Benjamin who
started a movement around sort of naming
and compiling the principles that
so-called classic liberals or true
liberals as he refers to them or
something like that what they stand for
and he's also bring critical actually of
some progressives for supposedly not
even knowing what they stand for that
they're only focused on policy and they
don't know what their principles are and
this movement that has an obsession with
the principles and ideas is really
really misguided and to be clear I'm not
saying principles are irrelevant and
that ideas shouldn't be discussed and
that it shouldn't be clear to one sort
of what their guiding principles are I
think it's very important to understand
what principles underlie our political
philosophy our life philosophy its
absence
lutely a sort of anchor or a set of
pillars upon which one can base more
specific policy positions why would
someone be for or against abortion well
you've got to understand sort of what
principles and basic ideas are at play
in your personal philosophy to then
guide you in making that decision but
this movement has expanded into
something that has actually become a
replacement for making difficult
decisions about policy when the
principles conflict which is almost all
the time almost all the time no set of
principles is going to give you the
answers to what it is that should happen
in society in the world of politics this
ideas movement overlaps in some ways
even though most of them would don't
know it they have no idea that it does
it's sort of overlaps with the positive
but with positivism the movement of
positivism sort of overlaps with the
principles of universalism which assert
that there are ideas with universal
application without really needing to
look at all the details of a particular
situation you've got your universal
principles and they apply everywhere and
give you the answers and I believe that
this ideas and principles movement is a
cop out it's a cop out from having to
really figure out difficult realities
that exist in the world and I want to be
clear this is not some postmodernist
cultural relativist whew right I'm not
praising or criticizing post-modernism
or cultural relativism in this segment
that's just not what this is plain and
simple and I'll try to make it clearer
with an example our friend Greg Stevens
emailed me a good example a couple
months ago of this lots of these
classical liberal pseudo libertarian
types will often say that two of their
guiding principles are the right to life
and the right to property and property
usually includes both physical property
and money the money that you earned all
right sounds good right nice principles
so to have a right to life in society
you really need a police force to
enforce that
there's going to be a right to life
through punishment for people who
violate the right to life of others as
an example if you're a police officer
you need to get paid because you need to
eat you need to live you need to feed
your family so very quickly you see that
to enforce the right to life of
everybody you need police and they need
a salary well okay if you say we'll put
a mandatory tax on people to pay for the
police
well according to many libertarians
you're violating the right to property
because you are taking the earned money
of people without their consent to pay
for police if you want to take a
different approach you say well this is
a libertarian utopia so you don't have
to fund the police people can choose to
fund the police but you only get police
protection if you pay well poor people
might want to fund the police but they
can't afford to so now if you're poor
you don't get the same right to life
that everybody else gets because you
can't afford it in modern Western
societies we've decided okay well
taxation to pay for the police is not
optional right we've decided in Western
democracies that it's more important to
have police to defend our right to life
and the police to protect everyone and
some of the freedom to decide what is
done with 100% of your money has been
removed you are going to if you're
earning wages pay for the police through
taxation how would the set of principles
give us that answer right remember going
back to our two principles they were a
right to life and a right to property
but as a society the decision was made
we're going to take away a little bit of
your right to property to prop up the
right to life
there's no set of principles you can
write down that will take into account
the complicated realities of the real
world period thinking that your
principles will give you the answer to
every political question is ridiculous
and where it gets dangerous is that
entire movements are being built around
the idea of unwavering and fixed black
and white principles and people aren't
doing the thinking anymore about the
CLEC cities of the real world a lot of
the so-called red pilling online
movement presents itself a sort of
exposing you to knowledge instead of the
sheltered ignorant that you've been
living under for your whole life but
it's often selective narratives that
will very frequently foment your belief
in some quite frankly arbitrary set of
principles without actually equipping
equipping you with the reality that
you're gonna need to deal with
complicated and messy issues in the
world it's actually a form of pseudo
intellectual ism in that by telling
people that they're doing the hard and
sophisticated work of establishing their
principles that they're really thinking
hard but the principles are actually the
easy part it's very easy to say our
principles are freedom or equality or
security or education or whatever right
but the real thinking is applying the
principles especially when they conflict
which is almost all the time
in the real world and I'd argue that
that's the more difficult part that we
should be focused on airport security
for example right we have a society
where our principles my philosophy is I
value security and I value freedom so
what do you do about airport security
which do you value more in what
proportions does the lack of freedom
that we have as a result of TSA and
no-fly lists and everything else that
there is does that loss of freedom
equate to or a does it seem valuable to
you in terms of the security that it
might add if we believe that it actually
gives us security just the principles
aren't going to get us anywhere
and people need to think way harder
about real world situations than the
principles of security and freedom when
we're talking about abortion except in
cases of absolute and total religious
dogma that is completely anti-abortion
which is that what I would which I would
argue actually excuses you from really
having to think hard most people
who have views on abortion that are
somewhere on the spectrum actually need
to evaluate multiple principles that
guide them in their lives these are not
simple answers and the idea that you're
gonna watch some YouTube videos and
develop some philosophy with a list of
five ten or fifteen principles and then
you don't really need to think hard
about every issue that's out there
because you're gonna get all the answers
from those principles is absolutely and
totally misguided and I think ultimately
we are dumbing down the political debate
through this movement which claims it
claims to empower people to really think
hard it's a problem I hope you'll send
me your feedback and thoughts about what
you think I'm very worried about that
movement I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
we will take a break and be back after
this with plenty more the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership